hi everyone its charlie you guys have
probably heard by now the DC has
officially cancelled all their movie
comic-con plans no Wonder Woman 1984
trailer no birds-of-prey trailer
even though DC doesn't really do movie
phases in the way that Marvel does phase
1 phase 2 phase 3 phase 4 they still
have big blocks of movies so you think
that they would also be announcing what
their next big block of movies is going
to be normally studio still give a big
blanket excuse about why they skip
comic-con but it's a little bit
different in the case of DC movies this
year there's really like six big reasons
and a lot of it has to do with what the
future of Warner Brothers is going to
look like because there's a lot of stuff
that's being changed behind the scenes
right now so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the easter-egg
videos there's a bunch of stuff coming
up in the next couple of weeks we're
doing a new round of the IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
DC movie on the video first things first
though DC TV will be at Comic Con
there's a bunch of panels I'll explain
what those are at the end of this
because I'll be showing off trailers
they'll be showing off the first episode
of a couple of new TV shows but normally
because the Joker movie Wonder Woman
1984 and birds of prey are the next DC
movies coming up you would think that
they would have comic-con panels like
the Joker is just coming up a couple
months after comic-con so why wouldn't
they have a big Hall H presence like
here check out this really weird really
cool Joker movie that we just made it's
gonna be totally idiosyncratic the
studio's official comment was that we're
not ready to show anything off yet but
if you remember last year at Comic Con
they did a Wonder Woman 1984 panel and
it only been shooting the movie for a
week or two and they still came and did
a comic-con panel so if they finished
shooting Wonder Woman 1984 earlier this
year then it's not like they don't have
footage to show off and birds of prey is
gonna drop in February so they're
probably even further along at
production so of course they would have
something to show off and we've already
seen the first Joker trailer so clearly
they have footage ready to go for that
really there are six big reasons why
they just opted to completely skip Comic
Con and a lot of it has to do with
what's going on with the other movies
and the structural changes they made
behind the scenes so number six you guys
may have heard about what's going on
with one
brothers in AT&T they just hired a brand
new CEO named Ann Sarnoff so she's
literally just starting her job right
now and trying to figure out what's
going on behind the scenes as they sort
of consolidate all their media because
18t just bought Time Warner which owns
Warner Brothers which owns all this
content that they're trying to
consolidate for their new streaming
service that's gonna launch in 2020 next
year
so all these executives are evaluating
which TV shows are gonna keep where
they're gonna put everything and there's
just a lot of structural stuff that they
have to figure out behind the scenes
also what they're gonna do with the
future of their DC movies slave-like
which movies and which TV shows that are
gonna develop next five next big reason
is because of JJ Abrams you wonder why
would JJ Abrams be a reason for DC
movies to skip comic-con well if you
didn't hear about it recently Warner
Brothers just won a bid with bad robot
studios JJ Abrams house where he
produces all of his movies as TV shows
to exclusively develop movies and
television shows for Warner Brothers in
AT&T now is a landmark deal you may have
heard about big creators being signed by
Netflix for hundreds of millions of
dollars greg berlanti who does all the
DC TV shows just got a 300 million
dollar deal so JJ Abrams is obviously
now the new crown jewel in Warner
Brothers stable of creators as you may
have seen in the last 10 years JJ Abrams
has kind of become known as the guy who
read develops and revitalizes huge
franchises what is a giant franchise
that is desperately in need of being
revitalized at Warner Brothers what a
surprise the DC Universe so you can bet
that all the other projects that JJ
Abrams is developing on his own his
original IP projects Warner Brothers
probably wants him to help them with the
DC Universe but the ink on the deal that
he just signed with Warner Brothers is
not completely dry yet so obviously
that's something that they would want to
announce like JJ Abrams is gonna be
developing all these huge TV shows and
movies for us and he'll also be doing
these next couple of big DC movies so
they're probably waiting for a lot of
contracts to settle before they can
announce a lot of those next big
projects so you wanted a really awesome
Green Lantern movie you wanted a really
awesome Man of Steel sequel JJ Abrams is
now probably the leading candidate for
those projects and number for the next
Justice League sequel if
buddy were able to handle something that
big JJ Abrams is one of those people
even though I think there are a couple
other directors out there that could
handle something that big and it's gonna
be a long time before we actually see a
Justice League sequel he's the kind of
safe bet slam dunk pic that Warner
Brothers and AT&T would feel good about
spending 250 million dollars on if they
were gonna try for another Justice
League movie in the next four or five
years if you remember though the new
mantra of the DC Universe is that even
though a lot of the stuff is still
connected they're not quite as connected
as the movies used to be before so
they're still letting each of the
directors kind of do their own things
with the movies and then when it comes
time for another big team up movie
they're sort of loosely tie things
together whatever that story that movie
winds up being it'll be relatively
self-contained you won't have to have
watched every single other DC movie to
get there if you don't remember way back
in 2002 around his Felicity days JJ
Abrams had a script for a Superman movie
called Superman flyby we actually have a
synopsis for that movie in a couple of
the storyboards so his actual sounds
pretty crazy
Superman flyby was an origin story that
included Krypton besieged by a civil war
between jor-el and his corrupt brother
cotta Zoar before Coty's or sentences
jor-el to prison kal-el is launched to
earth to fulfill a prophecy adopted by
Jonathan and Martha Kent he forms a
romance with Lois Lane in The Daily
Planet
however Lois is more concerned with
exposing lex luthor written as a
government agent obsessed with UFO
phenomena Clark reveals himself to the
world as Superman bringing catasaurus
son ties or and three other Kryptonians
to earth that sounds kind of familiar
really giving off some Richard Donner
vibes
Superman is defeated and killed and
visits jor-el who committed suicide on
Krypton while in prison in Kryptonian
heaven later Superman is resurrected he
returns to earth and defeats the four
Kryptonians while the script left off
with a Superman flying to Krypton
leaving a cliffhanger for a sequel so it
was sort of a remix of some of the
elements from the Richard Donner
Superman films as well as the death and
rebirth of Superman the only thing that
JJ Abrams has said about that movie
obviously they didn't wind up making it
is the thing that I tried to emphasize
in the story was that if the Kent's
found this boy kal-el who had the power
that he did
he would most likely have killed them
both in short order that sounds pretty
hardcore but you have to remember this
is JJ Abrams way back in the early 2000s
he goes on to say and the idea that
these parents would see if they were
lucky to survive long enough that they
had to immediately begin teaching this
kid to limit himself and not be so fast
not be so strong not be so powerful the
result of that psychologically would be
fear of oneself self-doubt and being
ashamed of what you were incapable of
extrapolating that to adulthood became a
fascinating psychological profile of
someone who was not pretending to be
Clark Kent but who was Clark Kent who
had become that kind of a character who
was not able or willing to accept who he
was and what his destiny was the idea of
the movie was that he became a Superman
because he realized he had to finally
own his strength in what he had always
been I don't know if that's what Zack
talking about Zack Snyder and
Christopher Nolan are doing but it looks
like that's part of the idea and I could
not be more thrilled to see that movie
that to me was always the way to go
so that was him talking about this
before the big Man of Steel reboot with
Henry Cavill so clearly he has some
ideas about the Superman character even
though I don't think that he would redo
his version of this old script he would
probably do something totally different
and I actually would rather see him do
Green Lantern just because it's
something that is a desperate need of
being revitalized at DC we've had at
least a couple good Superman films in
the past 20 to 30 years we have not had
a good Green Lantern movie yet so there
should be at the top of a lot of
people's lists and Green Lantern Corps
is actually the path to blackest night
war of light which is another big
justice league level crossover that they
could do in the future if everything
works out with the Green Lantern
franchise the other big reasons why DC
has to skip comic-con are because of
what's going on with the Batman right
now they're just not far enough along in
production they're not ready to show
anything off they don't want to give
away any concept art just because they
don't want people to start developing
preconceived notions about what its
gonna look like even though we know we
have Robert Pattinson we know we're
probably gonna get the penguin Catwoman
Riddler Firefly maybe a couple other
Batman villains but they haven't cast
the rest of those actors or actresses
yet and it's actually starting to seem
like they're doing a version of long
Halloween or the movie maybe dark
victory in long Halloween so if any new
details of
that leaked out I will do new videos
this summer no worries but then number
two because of the flash movie they
still have to figure out whether or not
they're gonna fire Ezra Miller or
they're gonna do his script that he's
developing with Grant Morrison which is
competing with a script from the
directors of the movie who are the two
writers of Spider Man homecoming they're
also doing their own script for the
flash movie and now Ezra Miller in a bid
to try and stay on as the flash because
his contract is almost up is trying to
develop his own version of a script with
Grant Morrison separately hoping that at
the studio does his script they'll keep
him on as the flash it's getting really
good it's getting really good enough you
know about anyone who knows anything
about Barry Allen knows that he's always
late but then when he arrives
so Warner Brothers just is not ready to
decide whether or not to hire or fire
Ezra Miller for this flash movie because
they're supposed to start shooting that
relatively soon and then lastly number
what also because of the Suicide Squad
they're getting ready to shoot that
really soon - and even though it sounds
like it's gonna be a really cool movie
they're just not ready to show anything
off and there was a big debacle with
James Gunn so there's just so much stuff
happening the DC is like you know what
we're gonna take a mulligan this year we
have all this TV stuff that we'll send
you guys can watch that that'll tide you
over
maybe we'll drop a couple of clips
sometime over the summer for Wonder
Woman no worries the bigger news they're
not to bury any of the leads though is
the future of the DC movie universe with
JJ Abrams and bad robot even though
they're still letting all the directors
do their own thing it does sound like he
might have a little more creative
oversight in what the bigger bigger
movies wind up being like patty Jenkins
has the Wonder Woman franchise on
lockdown so she's already sort of
talking about Wonder Woman 3 that's
basically gonna take care of itself but
there's so many other movies that they
need to take care of they need to figure
out what they're doing with the flash
what they're doing with Superman what
they're doing with the Green Lantern
Corps and what they're doing with their
Justice League team-up films so let me
know in the comments what DC movie do
you want JJ Abrams to do first
whatever that winds up being we probably
won't see it for another three years
bare minimum so right now my top picks
are Green Lantern Corps or a Man of
Steel sequel but all the DC TV shows are
still going to comic-con most of their
panels are happening Saturday night
they'll be dropping trailers for
everything they haven't completely
which of the DC Universe shows have been
canceled in which have been renewed
Titans is probably gonna be fine no
matter what they'll drop a Titan season
2 trailer they have jorah mormont from
Game of Thrones playing Batman during
season 2 he'll actually be walking
around you'll hear him talking in scenes
it won't be the weird thing where they
did before where he stands in the
shadows and you never actually see his
face
they've got Superboy they've got Krypto
they've got a new version of Deathstroke
Ravager Jericho then I think they're
gonna be a couple surprises I believe
that they're gonna do the Titans Tower
in San Francisco I'll do as many trailer
videos as I can but a lot of the DC
stuff on Saturday night is gonna overlap
with the Marvel Studios Marvel phase 4
panel so I'll figure out my schedule
when we get a little bit closer don't
worry it's gonna be crazy just like it
is every single year at Comic Con but
it's gonna be really cool while you wait
for everything click here for that Thor
guardians of the galaxy three teaser and
click here for that brand new spider-man
far from home trailer and learn about
venom crossover in future movies thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
see you guys tonight